A BEHIND-THE-SCENES LOOK AT THE
OPERATION TO FLY MIGRANTS FROM
TEXAS TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
CNN'S MARIA SANTANA SPOKE WITH
ONE MAN WHO WAS ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN RECRUITING ASYLUM
SEEKERS WITH PROMISES OF A
BETTER LIFE.
BUT NOW HE SAYS HE WAS DECEIVED
AS WELL.
>> Reporter: FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN CNN, SOMEONE ON THE INSIDE OF
THE OPERATION RECRUITING
MIGRANTS OUT OF SAN ANTONIO,
TEXAS, IS TELLING HIS STORY ON
CAMERA.
THE MAN WE SPOKE TO, HIMSELF A
RECENTLY ARRIVED MIGRANT,
DESCRIBING DETAILS OF WORKING
WITH A WOMAN WHO MANY HAVE SAID
IDENTIFIED HERSELF ONLY AS -- HE
SAYS HE WAS LIVING ON THE
STREETS OF SAN ANTONIO FOR 28
DAYS BEFORE HE WAS OFFERED FOOD,
CLOTHES AND MONEY TO HELP SECURE
MIGRANTS FOR THE FLIGHT TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
HE SHOWED US HER BUSINESS CARD,
TEXT MESSAGES AND LET US LISTEN
TO MESSAGES REVEALING SHE WAS IN
CONTACT WITH HIM AS RECENTLY AS
LAST WEEK.
FOR HIS SAFETY, WE ARE
PROTECTING HIS IDENTITY.
>> WHO APPROACHED YOU?
>> A WOMAN, SHE SAID HER NAME
WAS PERLA.
I DIDN'T KNOW IF THIS WAS HER
REAL NAME.
MY ONLY INTENTION WAS TO HELP
THE PEOPLE SO THEY COULD GET
STABILITY.
SHE TOOK THEM TO A HOTEL.
A THE HOTEL I REALIZED THEY WERE
BEING TREATED WELL.
THEY HAD LAUNDRY, CLOTHES,
THINGS THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE
EXPECTATION OF GETTING.
>> WHAT DID SHE SAY YOU HAD TO
DO?
HELP PEOPLE, RECRUIT THEM.
SHE SAID SHE WOULD HELP ME AND
DISTRIBUTE HER CARDS.
WE WOULD SEND THEM TO A
SANCTUARY PLACE.
UNTIL THE FLIGHT WOULD LEAVE, WE
WOULD TAKE THEM TO A HOTEL,
WHERE AS I EXPLAINED TO YOU,
THEY WERE PROVIDED SERVICES.
>> WHAT DID SHE SAY TO YOU TO
TELL THESE MIGRANTS WHEN YOU
APPROACHED THEM?
DID SHE GIVE YOU ANY
INSTRUCTIONS ABOUT HOW TO TALK
TO THEM, TO TRY TO GET THEM TO
GET ON THESE FLIGHTS?
>> Translator: SHE HAD TOLD ME
THE PEOPLE GOING TO
MASSACHUSETTS BEFORE I SENT
THEM, SHE HAD TOLD ME THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO RECEIVE THEM, THEY
WERE GOING TO LIVE, THEY WERE
GOING TO STAY, THEY WERE GOING
TO HELP THEM WITH THE LANGUAGE
AND THOSE WHO HAD CHILDREN, THEY
WERE GOING TO STUDY.
>> THESE MIGRANTS, MANY OF THEM
SAY THAT THEY WERE OFFERED $10
McDONALD'S GIFT CARDS AND THEY
WERE ASKED TO SIGN A CONSENT
FORM TO GET ON THESE FLIGHTS.
>> Translator: THEY GAVE THEM TO
ME SO THAT I COULD GIVE THEM TO
THEM WHEN PEOPLE WANTED TO BE ON
THE FLIGHT.
EVERYTHING WAS ALWAYS VOLUNTARY.
NO ONE WAS EVER FORCED TO DO
ANYTHING.
WHEN THESE PEOPLE ALWAYS SAID
YES, I MADE SURE THEY GAVE ME
THE PAPERS, THEIR MIGRATION
PAPERS.
>> Reporter: TWO PLANES LEFT SAN
ANTONIO ON SEPTEMBER 14th,
HEADED TO FLORIDA AND ULTIMATELY
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
ONCE THEY ARRIVED, HE RECEIVED A
CONCERNED PHONE MESSAGE FROM ONE
OF THE MIGRANTS.
>> Translator: WE ARE AT THE
UTOPIA, MAN, AND THERE'S
NOTHING.
WE'RE WAITING TO SEE IF WE CAN
FIND A BED BECAUSE I'M GOING TO
HAVE NO PLACE TO SLEEP.
THERE'S NOTHING HERE.
WE'RE ADRIFT.
THESE PEOPLE DIDN'T KNOW WE
WOULD ARRIVE.
I'M TELLING YOU EVERYTHING SO
YOU CAN SEE IT'S NOT ME, IT'S
THE REALITY.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS HE MESSAGED
THAT THE MIGRANTS WERE NERVOUS
BECAUSE NOBODY WAS THERE TO MEET
THEM AND THEY WERE SLEEPING ON
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
HE SHOWED US WHAT HE SAYS PERLA
TEXTED BACK, TELL THEM TO CALL
THE NUMBERS WE GAVE THEM, THE
CHURCH.
THE STATE HAS TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM.
SHE LEFT HIM AN AUDIO MESSAGE
SAYING I KNOW THEY WERE SCARED
SAT FIRST, BUT NOW THEY ARE IN A
MUCH BETTER PLACE AND THEY ARE
GOING TO BE TAKEN CARE OF THERE
LIKE YOU ARE NO IDEA.
I KNOW THEY ARE IN ANOTHER CITY,
BUT IT IS WITHIN MASSACHUSETTS.
BELIEVE ME, THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE A MUCH BETTER LIFE THAN
HERE OR ANYWHERE ELSE.
HE SAYS HE BELIEVED EVERYTHING
PERLA PROMISED HIM.
OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS HE SAYS
SHE'S BEEN WARNING HIM NOT TO
TALK TO REPORTERS, TEXTING HIM,
IF A REPORTER CALLS YOU, DON'T
SAY ANYTHING.
HE SAYS HE DIDN'T KNOW GOVERNOR
RON DeSANTIS WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE PLANES TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
UNTIL HE SAW THE NEWS, AND PERLA
NEVER INFORMED HIM WHO SHE WAS
WORKING FOR.
>> Translator: I WAS ALWAYS
AWARE THAT THERE WAS A BEN
FACTOR WHO WAS PAYING FOR
THINGS.
I REPEAT I NEVER KNEW IT WAS A
GOVERNOR OR POLITICIAN SO MY
ONLY WILL HAS BEEN TO HELP HIM.
>> Reporter: IN THE END I ASKED
HIM IF HE FELT BETRAYED BY ALL
OF THIS.
>> Translator: YES, VGS.
LOOK AT ALL OF THIS, WHERE I AM.
FIRST SO THAT EVERYONE KNOWS I
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
DECEPTION, SECOND THAT ALWAYS,
AS I SAID FROM THE BEGINNING, MY
ONLY PRINCIPLE HAS BEEN TO HELP
PEOPLE I REALLY SEE AS NEEDY.
>> Reporter: ALEX, THIS MIGRANT
TOLD US HE IS NO LONGER IN TOUCH
WITH PERLA AND SAYS HE FEELS
LIKE ANOTHER VICTIM OF THE
SCHEME, THAT HIS EXPERIENCE
SEEMS TO HAVE BE